Salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux.
Cet été, vous serez sûrement très nombreuses et nombreux
à vous prélasser sur les plages
et vous y serez
très bien accompagné
sur le sable, dans le sable et dans l'eau.
Une multitude de petits animaux ont élu domicile.
Evan de Bretagne qui n'a pas peur de se mouiller, va nous les présenter.
Salut Jamy, mais tu ne crois pas si bien dire.
Je crois que j'ai des puces.
Il y a des puces partout autour de ma serviette.
Enfin, je vous rassure quand même, ce sont des puces de mer.
Rien à voir avec celles qu'il y a sur le dos du chien de ma grand-mère.
En effet, rien à voir.
D'ailleurs, contrairement aux puces du chien de la grand-mère d'Evan
les puces de mer ou puces de sable ne sont pas des insectes.
Ce petit animal qui ne dépasse pas
25 millimètres
est un crustacé comme le homard ou la langoustine.
On trouve ces puces sur de nombreuses plages d'Europe.
Elles hibernent entre octobre et mars,
ce qui signifie qu'elles pointent le bout de leurs petites antennes aux beaux jours.
Justement, au moment où nous mettons les pieds sur les plages.
Avec leurs petites pattes, les puces de mer peuvent creuser jusqu'à
15 centimètres en profondeur
pour trouver de la fraîcheur
ou tout simplement pour s'abriter.
Et, lorsqu'elles sont à la surface,
elles font parfois des sauts de plus de 1 mètre.
Rapporté à leur taille, c'est énorme.
C'est d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on les appelle les puces de mer.
Décidément, ces bestioles sont pleines de surprises.
Par contre, pas touche à ma compote, les puces.
Si vous en voyez autour de vous ou sur votre serviette,
surtout, ne les écrasez pas.
Les puces de mer jouent un rôle important dans l'entretien de nos plages.
Elles font le ménage en aérant le sable et en se nourrissant
des déchets en décomposition, des restes d'algues, par exemple.
C'est pour cette raison qu'on les surnomme "éboueurs des mers".
Et puis, elles sont aussi une source de nourriture pour les goélands.
Vous le voyez ?
Ces petites puces sont précieuses.
Oh non, ma puce, elle est partie se cacher sous ma serviette.
Maintenant,
je vais vous présenter quelques spécimens
qui vivent sous le sable.
Suivez-moi.
Ah, j'adore marcher dans le sable humide !
Et regardez tous ces petits monticules de base,
c'est bien la preuve qu'il y a une vie souterraine, hyper active.
Le "ver arénicole" est un habitué de nos plages.
Il creuse des galeries en forme de U et ici, par exemple,
on peut clairement voir l'entrée de son trou.
Et, si vous vous demandez que sont ces petits monticules là,
et bien, en fait, ce sont ses excréments.
J'aurais peut être pas dû les toucher, en fait...
En creusant avec ses toutes petites pattes, que l'on appelle des "soies",
le ver arénicole se nourrit des sédiments et des bactéries
qui sont présents dans le sable et se débarrassent de surplus.
Chaque vers mesurent entre 15 et 30 cm de long,
ce qui en fait un appât très prisé par les pêcheurs.
Beaucoup plus surprenant,
ces vers arénicoles
possèdent des vertus thérapeutiques.
En Bretagne, des chercheurs qui travaillent au sein d'une start-up
ont découvert que leur sang a un grand pouvoir oxygénant.
Son hémoglobine peut fixer 40 fois plus d'oxygène
que l'hémoglobine du sang humain.
Mieux encore, il est compatible avec tous nos groupes sanguins.
L'hémoglobine du ver arénicole peut donc servir de substitut
pour les transfusions sanguines.
Or, vous le savez, on manque considérablement de sang.
Leur hémoglobine est également précieuse
en cas de transplantation d'organes.
Le sang de ce ver permet d'oxygéner le greffon, ce qui laisse
plus de temps pour le conserver intact durant son transport
jusqu'à la personne à transplanter.
Mais, Jamy, tu crois qu'il y a un risque qu'on se transforme en vers ?
Il a peur de trinquer.
Mais ces vers ne sont pas la seule richesse du sous-sol de la plage.
Vous êtes peut-être friand des coques, des palourdes ou des couteaux
qui se nichent dans le sable à chaque marée basse.
D'ailleurs, j'ai toujours rêvé de dénicher un couteau comme celui-ci, moi-même.
Est-ce que vous connaissez la technique ?
Regardez là, par exemple, on à 2 trous, ça pourrait être un couteau.
Il suffit de mettre du gros sel et normalement, le couteau sort.
Normalement...
Pas de chance Evan, tu n'es peut-être pas dans le bon trou
ou alors un autre pêcheur t'as devancé.
Mais pourquoi les couteaux sortent-t-ils de leurs trous au contact du sel ?
Tout simplement parce qu'on leur fait croire que la mer est remontée.
Son instinct le pousse, alors, à rejoindre la surface pour se nourrir.
Sauf que, malheureusement pour lui,
ce n'est pas de l'eau de mer qu'il trouve,
mais la main du pêcheur qui le capture pour en faire son repas.
Et je peux vous dire que les couteaux, c'est très très bon.
Jamy, je crois que j'en ai trouvé un.
Je ne vous avez pas dit mais j'ai un diplôme en effets spéciaux.
Maintenant que la mer est haute et
qu'on en sait plus sur les bestioles qui vivent sur et sous le sable.
Connaissez-vous Aurélie ?
C'est l'une des espèces de méduses les plus courantes en France,
au même titre que la Pélagie.
D'ailleurs, si vous les croisez, faites bien attention,
elles ont tendance à être un peu piquantes.
Il faut se méfier des méduses, ça pique.
Ceux qui ont vécu cette douloureuse expérience, s'en souviennent
en général, toute leur vie.
La méduse fait partie de la famille des cnidaires, comme les coraux.
"Cnide", en grec, signifie piquer.
Elles piquent avec de tout petits harpons qui recouvrent ses tentacules.
Quand une proie ou un danger s'approche
et touche les petits cils qui tapissent les tentacules,
le harpon se déploie à l'extérieur et va se planter dans les tissus de la victime.
Le venin est alors injecté.
L'opération ne dure que quelques millisecondes,
c'est l'un des phénomènes les plus rapides dans la nature.
En fait, si vous croisez une méduse échouée sur la plage,
c'est sûrement à cause des courants, des vents, des marées
qui l'ont entraînée et emportée vers les côtes.
Les méduses nagent mal,
alors, bien souvent, elles s'échouent sur le sable.
Elles vont mourir, malheureusement en séchant en plein soleil,
pendant les 6 heures de marée basse.
Même mortes, les méduses piquent encore.
Alors, si vous vous promenez au bord de l'eau,
faites bien attention à leurs filaments.
A ce sujet, vous voulez que je vous raconte ma vie ?
Oui, c'est super.
L'été dernier, j'étais à Gruissan, en Méditerranée,
et quand je suis allé me baigner, je n'ai pas vu de méduses.
Mais en fait, il y avait encore des morceaux de leurs filaments dans l'eau
et ça a suffi à me faire des petites irritations sur le bras.
Et oui, Jamy, t'as raison, je m'en souviens encore.
Que faut-il faire en cas de piqûre de méduse ?
Première règle, surtout ne pas frotter.
En frottant, on libère la totalité du venin contenu dans le harpon
et on risque des brûlures beaucoup plus sérieuses.
Il faut d'abord rincer à l'eau de mer,
j'ai bien dit l'eau de mer parce que l'eau douce provoque l'effet inverse,
elle provoque la libération du venin.
Ensuite, il faut piéger les harpons qui sont restés collés.
Et pour cela, il y a un produit miracle,
qui va peut-être vous surprendre, la mousse à raser.
Alors, je sais, il n'y en a pas dans notre sac de plage,
mais en général, il y en a dans tous les postes de secours.
C'est un buvard qui va piéger les harpons.
Ensuite, à l'aide d'un carton rigide,
une carte bancaire ou une carte d'identité,
eh bien on retire la mousse qui a emprisonné les harpons et le venin.
On rince une seconde fois à l'eau de mer,
puis, pour neutraliser le venin qui a été libéré, on arrose la zone touchée
avec un produit un peu acide, du vinaigre ou du citron.
Même chose, il y en a dans les postes de secours.
On rince à nouveau à l'eau de mer, puis on applique un antiseptique.
Bah, je croyais qu'il fallait faire pipi dessus, moi.
Surtout pas !
C'est une légende urbaine qui s'est propagée avec la série "Friends".
L'urine contient, en fait, de nombreuses bactéries
qu'il vaut mieux éviter de répandre sur la plaie,
au risque de causer une surinfection.
Hmmmm, les algues.
Ma grand-mère me dit toujours que c'est bon pour la circulation.
Pas étonnant qu'elle passe sa vie en thalasso.
D'ailleurs, il y a plein de petits animaux qui eux-aussi
apprécient ces paquets d'algues que l'on trouve au bord de la plage.
On appelle ça la laisse de mer.
Une petite salade d'algues, Jamy, peut-être ?
Prépare m'en une, j'arrive juste après la vidéo.
La laisse de mer est composée de débris déposés
par la mer et qui s'accumulent sur la plage au fil des marées.
Ces débris peuvent être d'origine naturelle, comme les algues, les coquillages,
le bois, des restes d'animaux.
Ou bien malheureusement d'origine humaine :
des bouteilles en plastique, des canettes de soda
ou des restes de filets de pêche.
La laisse de mer c'est un véritable garde manger
pour une ribambelle de petits animaux,
notamment les mouches qui pondent au fil des marées
et laissent leurs larves grandir dans les algues pendant plusieurs semaines.
Là, je cherche des cloportes, habitués de nos plages,
qui se nourrissent de morceaux de bois ou parfois de petits cadavres.
Bon appétit !
Ces algues séchées sont un vrai festin pour d'autres insectes,
mais aussi pour des araignées,
des araignées de dunes qui viennent dans la laisse de mer pour
chasser leurs proies.
Rassurez-vous, elles sont totalement inoffensives.
On y trouve également de nombreux crabes qui viennent se nourrir.
À ce propos, comment font les crabes pour respirer quand la mer est basse ?
Le crabe n'a pas de poumons, comme les poissons
il respire dans l'eau grâce à des branchies.
Chez lui, elles sont situées dans des cavités, il en possède 2.
Elles lui permettent de capter l'oxygène contenu dans l'eau
et d'évacuer le gaz carbonique contenu dans son sang.
Lorsqu'il est dans la mer,
ses cavités se remplissent et l'eau circule
en permanence autour des branchies.
Sauf qu'à marée basse, notre crabe n'a plus d'eau pour respirer.
Mais il a un truc, il ferme ses cavités
qu'il a pris soin au préalable de remplir d'eau.
Ces réserves vont lui permettre de continuer à respirer.
Bien sûr, ça ne peut pas durer éternellement, car vient un moment
où il a consommé tout l'oxygène dissous dans ses réserves.
Mais heureusement pour lui, la mer remonte toujours à temps
et notre crabe peut à nouveau respirer tranquillement dans l'eau, cette fois.
En été, certaines communes ramassent la laisse de mer
avec de gros engins de chantier pour des raisons purement esthétique.
Sauf qu'en faisant ça, on prive tout un écosystème de nourriture.
Alors la prochaine fois que vous verrez
ces grandes bandes d'algues sur le sable,
ne soyez pas dégoûté, dites vous plutôt que c'est une sorte de buffet
"all you can eat" pour toutes les petites bestioles de la plage.
D'ailleurs, Jamy, ça y est, il est temps que je me jette à l'eau.
Je crois, que je me suis fait piquer par une méduse.
Heureusement, mon caméraman a sûrement ce qu'il faut.
Non ? Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
On avait dit sur le bras, pas sur le visage, la mousse à raser.
Merci Evan.
J'espère que la mousse à raser va un peu apaiser tes douleurs.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à liker
et à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Et surtout, indiquez en commentaire les sujets
que vous aimeriez
que l'on traite avec Evan.
Bonne semaine à toutes et à tous, à la plage ou ailleurs,
et à dimanche prochain.